INTELLIGENCE TARGETS AND
INFILTRATE U.S. INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TO DO IT WITHOUT
ATTRIBUTION, BRET.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TRYING TO RALLY SENATE
REPUBLICANS TO PUSH THROUGH MORE
OF HIS NOMINEES.
AND IF TO PUSH HARDER TOWARD
HOLDING ONTO THEIR MAJORITY IN
NOVEMBER.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE A SEPARATE
PUSH AMONG SENATORS FOR SOME
KIND OF RESPONSE TO AN INSULT
AGAINST ONE OF THEIR OWN.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS DEALS WITH THAT
STORY TONIGHT FROM THE NORTH
LAWN.
>> JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO THE
PRESIDENT RETURNED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, HE HAD BEEN UP FOR
THE WALTER REED MEDICAL CENTER
VISITING THE FIRST LADY AS SHE
RECOVERS FROM A KIDNEY
PROCEDURE.
EARLIER TODAY HE WAS PUSHING HIS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME TO
CAPITOL HILL WITH A LOT ON HIS
MIND, FIRST AND FOREMOST OF SLOW
PACE OF CONFIRMATION FOR HIS
NOMINEES.
HE SAYS OBSTRUCTION IS STANDING
IN A WAY OF GETTING A STAFF IN
PLACE.
EXITING THE MEETING, SENATORS
PREFERRED TO FOCUS ON WHAT HAS
BEEN DONE RATHER THAN WORK
OUTSTANDING.
>> WE WERE ALL IN A CELEBRATORY
MOOD AS A RESULT OF HAVING
APPROVED AT THE FIRST CIRCUIT
JUDGE, JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A NUMBER
OF OTHER ITEMS ON HIS AGENDA TO
TALK ABOUT INCLUDING
APPROPRIATIONS, MAKING SURE HE
DOESN'T GET MORE OMNIBUS
SPENDING BILLS, FUNDING FOR A
BORDER WALL AND LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS FROM IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA.
THE PRESIDENT WILL ALSO PUSH
CONGRESS FOR IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THIS MORNING HE IS THE BACKDROP
OF THE NATIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
OF MEMORIAL SERVICE TO DRIVE
HOME THE URGENCY.
>> President Trump: THAT IS
WHY WE ARE CALLING ON CONGRESS
TO SECURE OUR BORDERS, SUPPORT
OUR BORDER AGENTS, STOP
SANCTUARY CITIES AND SHUT DOWN
POLICIES THAT RELEASE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WE DON'T WANT IT ANY LONGER.
WE HAVE HAD IT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> ONE TOPIC THAT DIDN'T COME UP
EVEN THOUGH IOWA SENATOR JONI
ERNST WANTED TO RAISE IT WAS THE
CUTTING REMARK THAT WHITE HOUSE
STAFFER KELLY SADLER MADE ABOUT
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN IN A
MEETING LAST WEEK.
A GROWING NUMBER OF SENATORS NOW
SAYING SADLER, THE WHITE HOUSE,
OR BOTH SHOULD APOLOGIZE.
>> OF THE PRISON HE SAID THAT
SHOULD APOLOGIZE AND SHOULD
APOLOGIZE PUBLICLY.
>> WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS TELL
FOX NEWS THAT SADLER COULD HAVE
EASILY PUT THE ISSUE TO REST BY
MAKING A PUBLIC APOLOGY TO
McCAIN LAST WEEK.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES THAT WAS
INITIALLY THE PLAN, BUT THE PLAN
CHANGED.
SADLER DUG IN HER HEELS AND SIX
DAYS LATER THE ISSUE WAS
GATHERING STEAM.
AND AN EFFORT TO CHANGE THE
SUBJECT PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THE
INSULT OF ALL ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IT WAS LEAKED.
MEANING THE SO-CALLED LEAKS
COMING OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ARE AN EXAGGERATION COMING OUT
OF THE NEWS MEDIA IN ORDER TO
MAKE US LOOK AS BAD AS POSSIBLE.
WITH THAT SAID, LEAKERS ARE
TRAITORS AND COWARDS AND WE WILL
FIND OUT WHO THEY ARE.
SOURCES SAY THERE WERE ABOUT 30
PEOPLE IN THE MEETING WHERE THE
REMARK WAS MADE AND OFFICIALS
BELIEVE IT WAS LEAKED SIMPLY TO
DAMAGE THE PRESIDENT, , AND THAT
THERE WILL LIKELY BE
REPERCUSSIONS.
>> I HAD SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS VERY TOPIC TODAY.
>> DO YOU EXPECT PERSONNEL
CHANGES AS A RESULT?
>> I DO.
>> KELLING AND CONWAY SAID A LOT
OF STAFFERS USE LINK TO "SHIV"
EACH OTHER.
WHITE HOUSE HAS SET IN THE